James O'Keefe has given a speech to uh I
guess I don't I I guess to staff at the
Veritas offices confirming that he was
removed from the CEO and from the board
he entered into the office and removed
his personal belongings that's what the
the reports are saying and project
Veritas has released a statement
accusing him of what appears to be
Financial malfeasance which I I do not
believe for a moment and one of the
things they complained about project
Veritas the board I guess accusing James
was that he used money for like funny
dance videos or events or something like
this and they called it like him
misappropriating funds well I want to
make sure I'm using this the care the
specific words they use but I'll just
put it this way I like that project
Veritas does dance events I like that
James O'Keefe is this figure is this
character that that brings life and and
a bit of levity to the to the work they
do